entre deux cours les élèves farfouille
parmi les rayons depuis ce matin une
friperie a pris place au lycée 17 mars
de maurepas des vêtements gratuits avec
derrière une sensibilisation à la
pollution textile on veut montrer à quel
point la position de textile c'est
vraiment une pollution qui impacte
beaucoup l'environnement en fait c'est
la deuxième plus grande pollution et si
on voulait dire que par exemple juste
pour créer un jim c entre 7000 et 10000
litres d'eau potable qui est gâchée
c'est assez simple de changer notre
manière de consommer
surtout dans la pollution textile parce
que ben en fait on peut re coût de nos
vêtements qu'on peut les réparer on peut
les personnaliser
et aussi il ya beaucoup de frais prix
qui existe pollution textiles mais aussi
numérique alimentaires et des transports
quatre thématiques sur lesquelles les
lycéens sont sensibilisés accompagnés
par leurs professeurs est organisé comme
un circuit dans un musée j'ai suggéré
l'idée de cette exposition
donc de choc
et les élèves donc les aides du cvl les
éco-délégués tous les élèves avec qui
ont travaillé sur le développement
durable ont été tout de suite très
partants et petit à petit on a construit
cette cette exposition des ateliers se
sont rajoutés ce projet qui devait être
petit à la base est devenu quelque chose
d'un peu impressionnant et franchement
je tiens à le dire l'équipe d'élèves qui
a travaillé sur ce projet sont
incroyables dire qu'ils se sont investis
à 300% penser dès novembre 2020 cette
éco festival est organisé sur deux jours
dans l'établissement mort patients